in sicherheit wiegen konnte man sich ja
nie
aber die armee stand eisern für
widerborstigkeit
wer sich mit der schweiz anlegt der wird
schon sehen
doch die welt dreht sich weiter
sichtbare gegner hatte das heer vor
allem im eigenen land und später gaben
ihm für den ernstfall nur eine chance
dass der feind sich toth lacht im kino
gab die truppe vor zehn jahren eine
schmissige schenkel klopft nummer her
ist helvetische tradition auch mike
müller hat als parodist einen soliden
ruf im truppenbesuch denn er mit bruder
tobi geschrieben hat ist das militär
aber bei aller komik keine reine
lachnummer gemacht offiziersuniform
auftrag der klasse dass ich auf einer
wiese ausgesehen
ich glaube für das ist zu wenig harmlos
dann mit hoch genug musik suche nach das
war grob verhalten
müllers methode heißt originalton in
projektionen treten armeeangehörige und
kritiker auf und müller schlüpft in ihre
rollen verzerrt ihre aussagen zur
kenntlichkeit hier als schul kommandant
nach ganzen offiziell gemacht dazu führt
er unter der woche bei fahrten tagen
wieder stark in augsburg bei takko oder
ein anderer fordert dazu mehr soldaten
der infanterie rs chur wie man kaum zum
glück zwingen musste porträtierte 1 sf
dokfilm letztes jahr lauter
hochmotivierte für sie ihre
wie sehen sie ihre gemeinsame zeit heute
ein jahr nach dem rs startet am liebsten
eine 20 wochen aber da ist so viel ich
habe mich es privat eigentlich vermisst
mit spaß mit den und mit spaß wie man
ihnen egal wie gemacht und kann ich in
züge und andere ist und das licht in die
wie immer mit dem hintergedanken dass
eben pflichtig erweckung ja sowieso
nicht kameradschaftliches wichtigste
militär und wenn man hier hätten wenn
gott die zieht aus so viel schneller
roma
aktuelle zahlen des vbs bestätigen
an motivation fehlt kaum 94% rühmen die
kameradschaft aber nur gut ein drittel
der soldaten sehen ihren dienst als
beitrag zur sicherheit des landes
schiffsführer unnötig und 1065 seinen
beruf
sie haben sie stelle referiert hat die
musik die man in das finde ich gut so
sie überhaupt erst mal passierte bis zu
verzeichnen und zwar finde ich das
absolute selber aufkommen doch insgesamt
absolut sinnlose sache
ich kann das nur dem unterschied dass
man anders kommen ergibt und dann muss
ich daraus machen romanseiten dann hat
es für mich als entwürdigend überlegt
sie hat ein imageproblem die
schrumpfende beste armee der welt von
der sich so der befund der gebrüder
müller ein teil der bevölkerung
abgewendet hat
ganz andere welt aus dem milieu
realisiert ist liberal bis links von der
mitte findet sie nur im stopp das ist so
verhandelt aber sie immer noch
legitimieren
doch die zweifler zahlen nicht mehr den
hohen preis von früher wie peter bichsel
er war soldat weil er lehrer und autor
sein wollte nicht professionelle armee
gegner eine entscheidung mit spätfolgen
die müsste dann mit dem 50
jetzt kommt aber jetzt zum thema